on l'a dit l'ukraine est une véritable
super puissance agricole avec sa
production de blé de maïs de tournesol
mais l'ukraine se démarque avec un autre
produit agricole
l'ukraine est le cinquième plus grand
producteur et exportateur de miel au
monde l'apiculture fait partie des
traditions là bas le pays compte plus de
400 mhz et l'apiculteur répartis un peu
partout sur le territoire c'est donc un
pour cent de la population qui possèdent
des ruches en comparaison il y as au
canada à peine plus de 10 mai
l'apiculteur depuis le début du conflit
l'agriculture est prise pour cible et le
secteur apicole n'est pas épargné par
les zones où ont lieu les combats on ne
compte plus les ruches is a cage et avec
deux cousins dimitro kushnir a fondé en
2016 une petite coopérative de
production de miel du terroir il voulait
se lancer dans l'exportation
mais le conflit est arrivée nous avons
cinq l'apiculteur
dont trois aujourd'hui sont en train de
faire la guerre ç'a un impact direct
donc les gars au lieu de nous faire du
miel ils font la guerre beaucoup des
ruchers sont laissés à eux mêmes au
moment où il faut sortir les abeilles de
leurs quartiers d'hiver à l'échelle du
pays on s'attend à des pertes colossales
de production les ruchers détruit je
deviens oui ça fait mal ça fait mal et
ce qui fait le plus mal le plus mal
c'est lévy sait les vies de gens qui
sont détruites ou qu'ils arrêtent de
détruire notre be